Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain a teen comedy film called
“Wild Child.” Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The story centers around a spoiled teenage
girl named Poppy Moore living in Malibu
with her widowed father and little sister.
Poppy’s mother died in a car crash long ago
and ever since her relationship with her father
Gerry hasn’t been the same. She hates him for
dating women who are not her mother. When his
current girlfriend is about to move in with them,
Poppy is furious. She invites her friends
and makes them destroy the woman’s belongings
that are being moved into the house.
It is not the first time she has pulled
a prank like this. Gerry is sick and tired of
her making his life more difficult. Till now,
he had been excusing her considering that she just
missed her mother but now that Poppy has crossed
a line, he wants to send her to a boarding school
in England. At first, she retaliates but Gerry is
determined to discipline her in the right way.
At night, Poppy and her little sister Molly talk
about her upcoming life in England. Poppy claims
she is relieved people in England at least speak
“American”. Molly realizes how out of proportion
her sister is to the real world. She hopes that
Poppy will learn something from her stay. The
next day, Poppy’s best friend Ruby helps her pack
and wishes her luck with England’s
weather. She also promises to take care
of Poppy’s boyfriend Roddy when she is away.
In the following scene, Gerry and Poppy arrive at
the boarding school in the countryside in England.
They are welcomed by the school’s headmistress
Mrs. Kingsley who promises to discipline Poppy in
no time. All other students are stunned to see her
in her over-the-top designer outfit. The head
girl of the school, Harriet also lands her eyes
on her and greets her with a handshake. She is
an egocentric and proud student who thinks she
runs the school. When Poppy refuses to respect
her, she is determined to teach her a lesson.
Poppy finally bids farewell to her
father and walks inside the school.
She soon finds out that she has to share a
bedroom with four other girls: Kate, Josie,
Kiki, and Drippy. She bluntly asks them to get
out because she wants to be left alone but the
girls only laugh at her. Then, she is told that
the girls are only allowed to use their phones
on the weekend but Poppy refuses to do so.
A while later, the hostel’s Matron comes to seize
their phones for the week. When Poppy talks to her
sarcastically, she, along with the other girls,
get detention as punishment. Poppy tries using her
old ways by bribing the Matron but it only gets
her in more trouble. On her first day of school,
she modifies the school uniform to fit her taste.
She wears high heels, a tight skirt, and
a cropped blazer, unlike the other girls.
Her roommates warn her that it might get her in
trouble but Poppy, as always, doesn’t care. Then,
she is told about the school’s prefect team
whose leader is the head girl, Harriet. She
has a crush on the school’s most popular bachelor
and the headmistress’s son named Freddie. One of
the important rules in the school is that no
girl is allowed to fraternize with any boys,
especially Freddie. The headmistress is
strictly against her son dating anyone.
At night before bedtime, the girls ask Poppy
how many guys she has slept with. On hearing
the long list, they are shocked because they have
been in the all-girls hostel since they were kids
and have no experience with boys whatsoever.
Later, the Matron brings Poppy a proper set
of uniforms to wear from the next day. Poppy
huffs at her and pretends to go to sleep. But
right after Matron leaves, she goes to the
computer room to email her best friend Ruby
about everything happening in her life. While
she is at it, she notices someone walking outside
the room. On checking, she finds Drippy in the
freezer having a late-night snack. Just then,
a fire drill takes place and Poppy is stuck in
the hallways. To not get caught, she climbs on
the roof and enters a bathroom. The bathroom turns
out to be Freddie’s who tells her the way out and
promises to keep her visit a secret.
The following day, Poppy is taken into
the school’s lacrosse team. The diva in her is
horrified at girls running around covered in
sweat. But when the head girl Harriet challenges
her to a one-on-one match, she accepts it. They
launch at each other but instead of hitting the
ball, they start to fistfight. Harriet stops only
when Freddie’s car passes by. She is smitten by
him and hence is horrified when he greets Poppy
a good morning. After he drives off, Poppy makes
fun of her for being in love with him. Harriet
runs to her dorm room which consists of several
pictures of Freddie, proving her obsession with
him. She panics about how he knew Poppy’s name but
comes to the conclusion that he was just trying to
hide his love for her by talking to a random girl.
A while later, Poppy is called by the headmistress
who is disappointed at her for starting a fight.
She knows that Poppy is not a bad person and
hopes that she will do better in school from
now on. Poppy is amazed by the headmistress’s
expectations. For the first time after her
mother’s death, someone has shown faith in her.
Later that day, Harriet is in her room, when she
notices Poppy sitting right below the window.
She makes her minion dump a bucket of water on
her and pretends like she didn’t know someone
was downstairs. Poppy has to rush to her room
shivering. She misses her friends from back home
and is feeling homesick. One of her roommates
named Kate notices this and offers Poppy a
jumper for her cold. Poppy feels at home with
Kate and tells her about her mother’s death
that happened five years ago. The two talk
about their past and form a bond that Poppy
had never thought she would make with someone
from the school. Kate also gives her a secret
phone so she can call her friends in America.
Poppy calls Ruby who turns out to be sleeping with
Poppy’s boyfriend Roddy. They fake being concerned
for her and end the call. Right after, Ruby makes
fun of Poppy’s appearance and continues making out
with her boyfriend. That night, Poppy’s roommates
decide to help her get expelled from school, which
is the only way she can go back to America. Since
she so desperately wants to go home, they feel
sympathetic and want to help. Poppy is overwhelmed
by the love they show to her even though she has
been nothing but rude. Starting the next day,
they play a plethora of pranks; dying the
swimming pool’s water red, prank calling Harriet,
and spreading rumors about their teachers making
out in the school. For the last one, Poppy gets
into trouble. She is called to the headmistress’s
office but is let go after a simple warning. The
girls register that the headmistress is letting
Poppy off the hook because she is Gerry’s
daughter. Hence, they will have to do something
out of the ordinary to get her in trouble.
When they are in the bath one day, they think of
a brilliant idea. One thing the headmistress hates
is her son getting close to any girls from the
school. This means if Poppy made out with him,
she is bound to be expelled. The next day is
the themed dance party where the people from
the boy’s school will also come. Although
the party is “pride and prejudice” themed,
Poppy and her group decide to do something extra.
They go to the town to shop for the big day
and have a lot of fun. Poppy also changes her hair
color to brunette which makes her look exactly
like her mother. They secretly steal liquor from
a shop, planning to get wasted at the party.
The following evening, everything is going
well. The students are properly dressed,
especially Harriet who is dressed as Elizabeth.
She bores Freddie by talking to him in lines
from the book. The party is interrupted by Poppy
and her group making a grand entrance in their
short modern dresses. Harriet is horrified
but the same cannot be said for Freddie.
He seems to be attracted to Poppy. The night
turns into a nightmare for the head girl
when Freddie and Poppy dance together. She quickly
changes the song to an upbeat one so people would
dance individually. Her plan works but then, Poppy
dances alone and steals the show. Later, she and
Freddie come outside for some alone time. Harriet
sends her minions to keep an eye on them.
As the two talk, Poppy realizes Freddie is a quite
interesting man who actually cares about people.
He leans in to kiss her but the minions interrupt
them. The girls decide not to tell Harriet because
she will make their life miserable trying to
separate Freddie and Poppy. Poppy then returns
to her friends who are having the time of
their lives with the boys. As they talk,
she confesses that she has never been intimate
with anyone and used to be ashamed about it
back home. Hence, she lied to them at first but
now she feels like she can tell them anything
without the fear of being judged. She also
reveals that she might actually like Freddie,
not just for the purpose of the prank.
The next day, Poppy is invited to play lacrosse
after Drippy gets sick. She discovers
her talent for the game and the team
wins for the first time because of her.
The next day in the morning assembly,
the headmistress announces that their junior
lacrosse team has been selected to play in the
inter-school competition for the first time in
more than a decade. She asks the participants to
talk to Harriet if they have any concerns. But
then, she corrects herself because the students
should now go to Poppy instead of Harriet.
Harriet glows red in anger at the announcement.
Starting the next day, Poppy whips the school's
team into shape, getting them into the finals
of the competition. Then, one day, she is invited
to a date with Freddie. Before going, she is on a
computer sending emails to her friends back home.
She forgets to log it off resulting in someone
else mishandling her email. Freddie and Poppy
go on a date and talk about different things.
They discover they have a lot in common and start
to fall for each other. On returning to her room,
Poppy finds her friends reading an email
exposing that she thinks of them as losers.
The group assumes that the email was sent by
her and is furious. She tries explaining but the
girls are so hurt that they refuse to listen. When
Poppy goes to Freddie to talk, she finds out that
he has also received a similar email, exposing
that she is only using him to get expelled.
With no one else to turn to, Poppy sneaks
down to the cook's room and calls Ruby.
She initially pretends to be interested
in what Poppy is talking about but then,
accidentally reveals how much she dislikes her.
Poppy feels the lowest she has ever been. She
gets lost in her thoughts and starts playing with
her lighter which accidentally sets a curtain on
fire. She immediately puts it out and runs outside
after hearing footsteps approaching. When she is
back in her room, she looks out her window to see
the fire that she thought was put out has spread.
She quickly wakes everyone up but finds out that
Drippy is missing. On realizing that she might
have snuck out for a late-night snack, Poppy
goes to save her. With the firefighter’s help,
they manage to get her out safely.
When the fire is extinguished, Freddie
finds Poppy’s lighter in the mess and assumes
she was the one who lit the fire to get expelled.
He refuses to hear any explanation and gives
the lighter back to her. Later that day,
Poppy decides to do the one right thing and
takes the blame for the fire. The headmistress
is disappointed in her but she acknowledges
the fact that Poppy decided to be truthful. She
declares that a hearing will be held at the Honor
Court to decide what they should do next.
In the following scene, Poppy finds a portrait
of her late mother in the 1976’s lacrosse team
and begins to cry upon realizing her
mother had attended the same school.
While she waits for the Honor Court hearing,
Freddie finds and is convinced the fire was
just an accident. At the same time, Drippy and
the group match the time that the email was sent
and realize that someone had tried to sabotage
their friendship with Poppy. At the hearing,
Poppy gives her testimony. Harriet interrupts
her several times and tells her how horrible of
a person she is to put everyone’s lives in danger.
When everyone else speaks in Poppy’s favor,
she panics and accidentally mentions the
lighter. No one had ever said anything about
the lighter and no students other than Freddie
knew about it. This proves that Harriet was the
one who lit the curtains on fire after Poppy
ran away. She confesses that she did it but
tries to rationalize it as finishing what Poppy
started. In the end, Poppy is let free without
any charges while Harriet is expelled.
In the last scene, Gerry comes to visit his
daughter and watches the lacrosse finals game.
Poppy's dramatic change in appearance and attitude
surprises him. They win the match, thanks
to her leadership. The father and daughter
reunite after the game and hug.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.